grace deja un rastro de destrucción a su
paso por el sureste de méxico y varios
muertos y desaparecidos con categoría 3
golpeó en primer lugar la localidad de
tecolutla provocando daños en el 90% de
la zona
no sabía cómo tronaban los palos que
caían y todos los astros pero estoy muy
orgullo de todos
tenía mucho miedo
una noche creéis también golpeó con
fuerza en el estado de veracruz estaba
cayendo me di la vuelta para meterme a
la casa
y se des la vuelta y se te quedaron
abajo todos mi esposa y mis seis niños
en plena temporada de tormentas los
habitantes del estado de nueva york
siguen de cerca las previsiones
meteorológicas mientras se preparan para
la llegada del huracán henry que se
espera toque tierra el domingo en long
island o el sur de nueva inglaterra que
no ha recibido el impacto directo de un
huracán desde 1991
hemos visto cómo algunas tormentas
torrenciales destruyen casas y se llevan
la electricidad durante semanas así que
por qué no prepararnos para lo peor y
esperar lo mejor
el polémico gobernador saliente de nueva
york andrew cuomo ordenó a los
organismos estatales que preparen los
medios de respuesta para la emergencia
esto a los ciudadanos a quedarse en casa
new yorkers guys newyorkinos por favor
tomen esta tormenta en serio sé que es
un aviso de corto plazo piensen en la
súper tormenta sandy fue categoría 1
este es de categoría
en su camino a las costas del noroeste
de eeuu henry se transformó este sábado
en de categoría 1 con vientos de 120
kilómetros por hora